nous sommes en caméra cachée à la
clinique du pied de sainte thérèse ou ne
travaillent aucun podiatre en quelques
minutes
notre complice qui consultent pour un
oignon reçoit un diagnostic fait cela on
est modifié nous avons montré le
résultat à une pédiatre c'est pas juste
des recommandations cd20 et stx et de la
pratique illégale la peau théâtre il
sait chacun c'est ses chats qu'un parce
que c'est pour le public ou si c'est
décevant pour eux demain pour savoir qui
vont même pas consulté un vrai
professionnel contrairement aux
podologue dont la formation n'est pas
encadrée par la loi et qui doivent se
limiter à des soins de base comme des
piqûres donc on va utiliser des
instruments stérile et podiatre eux
peuvent poser des diagnostics qui
prescrit des traitements
parce qu'ils ont complété un doctorat en
médecine podiatrique et sont membres
d'un ordre professionnel
on a de plus en plus dénoncée à fillon
le plan plainte l'ordre des podiatres du
québec d'y enquêter en moyenne sur une
vingtaine de cas d'exercice illégal par
année et c'est là que c'est dangereux
parce que on a des cas où l'abbé
blessures des brûlures des coupeurs des
infections ou d orthez qui sont rendus à
des gens qui en ont besoin
au lendemain de notre visite à la
clinique de sainte-thérèse des
accusations pour exercice illégal ont
été déposées contre trois employés pour
des pratiques qui auraient lieu de 2016
à janvier de cette année deux des
accusés
brigitte bouchard et mario étiez avait
eu déjà plaidé coupable à un chef
d'accusation pour des gestes posés entre
2010 et 2014
ils sont ensuite allés pratiqués
ailleurs mario étiez ni poser des
diagnostics
c'est pas normal d'aider qu'on fait un
travail qui est actionnaire
mais les zambiens droit pourquoi la pop
une équipe dont sont épiés parfaite ges
des côtes dont
nous sommes donc tête manquée localités
comme je suis en général ces progrès des
coupables si vous faites juste la coupe
d'ongles parce qu'on ne s'est pas
défendu l'homme maintenant ça suffit
à quand la plus loi de rien fait je te
dis bonjour comment je remplis ton
dossier mais ses réserves alors non il
faut savoir maintenant si à droite fait
quoi c'est pour ça qu'on s'envoie luanco
pourtant la loi est claire
d'ailleurs le cas de la clinique de
sainte-thérèse est aussi dans la mire du
collège des médecins pour le collège et
l'ordre des podiatres du québec
l'important est avant tout de s'assurer
au même titre que le psychologue et un
ingénieur qu'on a à faire un membre d'un
ordre professionnel il si marc loranger
l'aîné radio canada montréal